[Musique]
salut tout le monde alors dans cette
vidéo je vais vous montrer quelques
petites astuces pour améliorer votre jeu
avec vos cavaliers que ce soit en blitz
ou en partie longue
allez on va commencer avec un cavalier
seul sur l'échiquier donc là on voit
tous ses déplacements
mais nous ce qui va nous intéresser
c'est de voir comment ils se déplacent
sur les cases qui sont proches de lui
alors on va commencer par des cases
facile ce sont celles en diagonale d'une
case par rapport aux cavaliers pour
aller sur ces cases là il lui faut deux
coups donc n'importe laquelle on va
prendre la case des cinq un coup de
coude ou un coup de coûts a donc facile
à la case d3 ça va être pareil un coup
deux coups un coup de coup et comme ces
symétrique
on va pouvoir faire la même chose sur
n'importe laquelle de ses cases en
diagonale maintenant on va jeter un oeil
sur les cases qui sont juste devant
derrière et à côté du cavalier alors
pour ces cases là ça va être un peu plus
long il va falloir trois coups 1 2 3 1 2
3 1 2 3 à noter que pourra aller sur
chacune de ces cases ya plusieurs
chemins différents que je suis en train
de vous mettre à l'écran alors je vais
pas tous les faire mais c'est pour vous
montrer qu'il ya souvent avec arval un
cavalier plusieurs manières d'aller
sur une même case donc il faut à deux
coups pour les cases en verre je vais
rajouter aussi celle ci un coût pour les
cases en bleu celle que je vais pas lui
mais ce seront les développements direct
et maintenant on va regarder les cases
deux fois en diagonale sur lesquels il
va falloir quatre coups pour se déplacer
donc celle en rouge donc ce sont des
casques qui sont très éloignées il va
nous falloir un deux trois quatre et
l'appareil
on peut utiliser tout un tas de chemin
pour aller sur une même case
évidemment plus le chemin est long plus
il y aura de parcours possible avec un
cavalier qui mettront quatre coups donc
ça c'est quand même intéressant comme
schéma donc je le rallume de cases comme
ceci donc sur ce genre de petits à rosas
je sais pas comment appeler ça et quatre
cases donc voilà je les remets sans les
flèches
ça va être quelque chose qui va qui va
vous servir pour savoir un petit peu
comment se déplacer on va voir des
exemples pratiques
alors j'ai pris une petite position
marrante
dans une partie quelque chose de
possible pour aller un peu plus loin que
ses déplacements de cavaliers imaginons
que je veux y amener mon cavalier b1 sur
la case f5 parce qu'on sait quand on
ramène un cavalier sur f5 c'est une
bonne pièce d'attac par rapport au roi
eh bien il va me falloir quatre coups
donc là c'est mon 4 cases en diagonale
il se trouve que ces quatre courts ici
et on va voir une nouvelle fois qu'il ya
beaucoup de chemin alors un plan
classique souvent pour la nef 500 mètres
la tour e 1 puis de faire cavalier des
deux cavaliers f1 qu'avait léger trois
cavaliers f5
mais en réalité il ya plein d'autres
manières d'atterrir sur cette case il ya
cavaliers ces trois caves a lieu 2 kg
trois cavaliers f5 qui peut être un plan
il y aurait cavaliers c3 qui a aidé 5 si
on est ambitieux et que cette case était
accessible cavaliers trois cavaliers f5
car il y ait ces trois cavaliers d un
cavalier trois cavaliers f5 pourrait
aussi être un plan pourrait très bien
même aussi j'ai déjà vu des partis comme
ça passait par à 3 puis ces deux ou c4
pour revenir en 3 et rejaillit revers f5
ou ou des 5
donc quand vous avez un cavalier
vraiment regarder soyez ouverts à
d'autres chemins parce que quand il ya
beaucoup de coups pour aller d'une case
à à une casse béthune quasi sibérien à
une case f5
il n'y a pas qu'un chemin y en a
généralement une multitude et donc il
faut essayer de se dire ah tiens en
passant par là je ferai ici en passant
par part si je ferai ça c'est pour
s'imprégner de ça c'est important
alors on va se mettre sur quelques
exemples pratiques ici les blancs sont
en échec
quelle case choisiriez vous pour votre
roi alors généralement les deux cas ce
qu'on regarde en premier quand un car
elle nous en échec genre surtout quand
on est en blitz on n'a pas le temps de
réagir il nous reste peu de temps c'est
soit la case de foot de en diagonale
parce qu'on sait qu'on est loin du
cavalier qu'il aura du mal à nous
remettre en échec ou faire une
fourchette ou juste devant parce que ça
permet d'attaquer le cavalier tout en
étant à une distance lointaine puisque
comme on l'a vu il faudra deux coups
dont trois coups pour atteindre la case
mais deux coups pour le mettre en échec
germes ans et les deux cas ce qu'on
regarde en premier ici je serais parti
en d3 parce que j'ai envie d'aider
d'attaquer le car et les gagne un tempo
un temps sur le cavalier et envoyer mes
pions aal.l allèles dame
donc j'aurais choisi roi des 3 mayroy f2
aurait aussi été un coup je vais avoir
leur exemple jusqu'à près qui peut qui
peut se regarder
après il peut arriver très bien que soir
au roi des deux coups un ca veut passer
c'est pas toujours ça ou ça mais c'est
quand même les premiers coups les
premiers coups réflexes et l'a
d'ailleurs par exemple sur war3 man
lecavalier pourrait directement nous
remettre en échec et attaquer le pion g3
donc si on veut le protéger faudra
repartir en f3 ou en f2 et on aurait
perdu un tempo allez je mette un autre
petit exemple j'ai rajouté des pièces
j'ai rajouté une tour en des huit ans un
des pions et un cavalier pour les blancs
l' échec ou vous partez à m avec votre
roi et black important de partir en f2
parce que si on va sur la colonne des
portions vendée de you're et cavaliers
detroit et chaque mois serait double
échec mais toutes les cases de la
colonne des as nous on se prendrait une
découverte et on perdrait la tour donc
la colonne des la case d3 aussi
impossible que trois pour attaquer %
s'approcher du cavalier bas l'appareil
up cavale et ses deux échecs et c'est
carrément une fourchette
ça c'est pas de chance et du coup
d'envoir envie de s'éloigner du roi est
allé en f2 comme ça le cavalier a du mal
à nous mettre en échec et si celui ci
bouge
pour jouer à tour d2 et on aura le temps
de faire tourner un pour colmater la
colonne vu qu'elle est protégée
cette tour par le cavalier à noter que
si on était allé en f1 donc on n'est pas
suivi notre règle de la diagonale les
noirs auraient pu jouer cavalier ces
deux avec l'idée sur tours d un de jouer
cavalier e 3 échecs fourchette est de
gagner une qualité donc sur cavaliers
ces deux on n'aurait pas pu jouer autour
des 1 on aurait peut-être joué un coup
comme tour c1 mais la tour noire serait
rentré en deuxième rangée et ça nous
aurait posé deux petits problèmes
donc là encore la règle on est en échec
les deux premiers coups en garde royale
de roide et 3 je me répète ce sera pas
toujours les bons mais quand même c'est
ça marche souvent du coup autre petit
truc pratique quand on joue là pour la
peine contre un cavalier une méthode et
une finale avec une qualité de plus
alors on reviendra peut-être sur comment
gagner ce genre de finale dans la vidéo
sur les tours mais juste pour vous dire
que tant que vous gardez votre roi sur
cases noires et votre tour sur case
blanche
il peut pas y avoir de fourchette parce
qu'un cavalier n'attaque soit que des
cases noires soient que des cases
blanches donc battant qu'on est sûr
couleur différente pas de fourchette 3
tout ça peut aussi la être très pratique
quand on a peu de temps à la pendule ou
qu'on commence à plurien voire même
parti donc parfois même même s'il nous
reste dix quinze minutes la partie a
duré 4 5 heures et on n'arrive plus à
avoir au moins on est sûr case noire
caisse blanche y aura jamais de
fourchette c'est impossible
alors maintenant on va jeter un oeil à
aux cavaliers contre un pion alors
généralement le cavalier peut arrêter
tous les pions alors sauf les pions à 2
et h2 que je vous montrerai juste après
mais avec les pions même en a trois on a
l'impression que notre cavalier va se
faire chasser donc à detroit mais ton
roi ces deux cavaliers b4 et chaque
croix b 3 donc là on a l'impression que
le cavalier est chassée de la casa 2 il
en a plus le contrôle mais il va pouvoir
repasser par détroit et sur a2 faire
cavalier c1 et moi j'appelle ça un petit
carrousel
le cavalier fait un tour sur ces cases
et il va jamais le roi noir va jamais
pouvoir l'empêcher de revenir donc un
cavalier peu arrêté à moins qu'il y ait
des obstacles un pion même à face à mais
même si le roi l'aide lecavalier
arrêtera le pion donc le seul pion qu'on
va pas réussir à arrêter c'est le pion à
b2 puisque le roi à deux ou h depardon
pas bête de ma 2e puisque le roi va
pouvoir s'en approcher et lecavalier ne
va pas pouvoir revenir à défendre cette
case
en tout cas ça il va se faire manger
ensuite les cavaliers sont plus forts
que les fous dans les positions fermes
et ici excellente exemple à l'oeuf ou de
casques blancs je suis les complètement
emmuré dans ses propres pions il peut
pas aller plus loin bessette 17
évidemment éventuellement naviguer vers
f7 ou h7 avec difficultés se font en
temps mais il pourrait quand même le
faire le fou de cases noires lui il est
embourbé dans les pions blancs et les
cavaliers peut théoriquement il pourrait
alors les quinze ans est protégé mais il
pourrait se balader sur n'importe quelle
case de l'échiquier en slalomant entre
les pions alors là les fous vont réussir
à défendre mais en gros on sent la
supériorité des cavaliers sur les fous
dans les positions fermé et on parlera
des positions ouvertes sur dans la vidéo
sur les fous parce que les fous sont les
pièces longue portée et donc vont faire
mal aux cavaliers lorsqu'il ya peu de
trafic
alors ici petit exemple pratique d'une
domination du cavalier
sur le fou avec ce fou qui est un petit
peu embourbé dans les pions blancs et le
cavalier lui qui a une superbe case en 5
d'où il contrôle beaucoup de casse dans
le camp adverse et il peut même
éventuellement faire un plan pour
jaillir via des trois ans et cinq pour
s'en prendre aux pions à 6 et aussi ce
donc grande liberté ici pour le cavalier
face aux fous et donc avantage blanc
alors après finale à travailler et à
gagner mais là on sent que le cavalier
est supérieur aux fous à noter que si
les noirs alain foot calme noir il
pourrait éventuellement venir vers des
sites éviter les fourchettes avec un
balai à vii ou quoi est ce c'est changer
avec le cavalier en cas de besoin qu'ils
soient en c5 ou ans le 5 mai la fougasse
blanche
il est pas terrible terrible en revanche
ce qu'il faut absolument éviter autant
que possible avec un cavalier contre un
fou c'est de se prendre ce que vous
voyez ici à l'écran et qu'on appelle une
focale c'est à dire que le cavalier est
dominé par le fou qui est centralisé et
qui empêche toute sortie du cavalier en
contrôlant toutes ces cases une focale
peut exister comme ça elle pourrait
aussi exister comme ça pardon à en
contrôlant toutes les cases du cavalier
ici on fera avancer le fou d'une rangée
mais voilà on peut ça peut ça peut
exister de tous les côtés et il arrive
parfois que contre un cavalier en f3 je
vous rajoutez quelques petits pions ce
soit réaliste un fou un f6 soit assez
fort ça fait un genre de 2 me faut caler
évidemment il suffit que je dise ça pour
que les pions se met pas mais ça fait un
genre de de semis focale où on contrôler
toutes les cases du cavalier vers
l'avant il pourra encore se réussit les
vrd 2,4 ou quoi mais quand même on a un
fou qui se mit domine le cavalier on va
dire qu'il sera obligé de de trouver un
rebond donc les fous peuvent peuvent
parfois avoir cette cette bonne position
par rapport aux cavaliers trois cases
devant et pour finir je vais vous parler
du duo dame cavaliers qui est connu pour
être un excellent duo d'attaquants dit
que la tour et le foot joue bien
ensemble et que la dame et le cavalier
joue bien ensemble et ici ça va bien se
voir lecavalier va venir en f 5 pour les
blancs et on voit qu'ils contrôlent la
case e72 sortie pour le roi et la case
g7
pour s'appuyer avec la dame et permettra
la dame de devenir justement faire ce
matin angers7
et souvent cette distance allait bien
parce que lecavalier il est un petit peu
loin de la tacc il est à trois cases du
roi donc il n'est pas trop avancer dans
le camp adverse
et pourtant il aide la dame sur deux
cases très importante pour qu'elle
puisse arriver alors si le roi parents
et fuite
il voudra pas s'échapper via le centre
grâce aux cavaliers on va pouvoir le
bloquer via damage 5
admettons tous réussissent pour ce faire
de l'espace dame prend h7 roi 8 dames g8
3,17 et dames price est et on voit que
lecavalier était utile assure sur les
droits et il est utile aussi au centre
en contrôlant cette case de cette donc
là soit on part envers la tour soit
tours 7
et on perd une qualité et si le roi donc
sur cavani afsset f5 pardon était parti
en ashmeed ce qui est meilleur on aurait
pu jouer
damages 5 à venir s'en prendre aux pions
à f 7 et sur n'importe quel coût comme
dame des sept dont on va pouvoir faire
damage 6 on va attaquer j'ai cette
menace et le math et à s'en prendre aux
pions avec 6 à noter qu'on pouvait pas
protégé f6 f7 avec la dame vient dame de
parce que à bas le cavalier contrôler
cette case ossètes et sur un coup comme
touré fuite et qui était plus fort on
aurait continué paroisse h1 et f4 pour
ramener la tour et on voit que ce
cavalier est vraiment un empêcheur de
tourner en rond et que le m'attend h7
peut arriver rapidement
j'espère que ces quelques petits astuces
sur le cavalier vous aideront dans vos
parties et on se retrouve très bientôt
pour parler d'autres pièces à bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]